after she let Nick Fury down with Hydra
Nick Fury it's like who can I trust
extraterrestrials let's try to keep them
safe in the field and the secret
invasion is actually something that we
need so it's not a scroll secret
invasion it's actually these mindwiped
characters that we've seen and known
from the other from the other timeline
now bringing brought into the MCU
timeline I think Pym is actually also
whoa wait and we are talking about how
everyone we know and love is secretly a
scroll the whole time no one associate
with no one who are you yeah I felt
Melina real cool yeah Thank You Josh
Rove enjoy thank you yeah you're
probationary period as marina Mastro's
neighbors on probation every time scroll
searches bag baby there's a rumor that
Marvel's adapting the 2008 comic
storylines secret invasion into maybe
possibly
almost all sale plus a mother Disney
please Pinchot and or a movie so the
story would involve this girl's posing
as superheroes and then it's a plot to
take over the world
secretly you know one here at a time so
we meet the squirrels in the MCU and
Captain Marvel already and they also
showed up again in spider-man far from
home in that post-credit scene so I need
to hear some rogue theories on how
Marvel could set up this plot Eric's
point praying this goes well I need to
hear some real tears on how Marvel could
set up this plotline in these upcoming
releases that are you know throughout
2020 and how it's gonna play out for the
MTF next phase okay I have an idea of
course I have like a billion scroll
different ideas but as you said we did
see it in the post-credits scene a
Spider Man far from home
that Nick Fury and Maria Hill were
actually Scrolls Sauron and Talos posing
as them we saw Nick Fury on the space
station with a bunch of squirrels
looking for issues so we've had some
theories that we could be looking at
Marvel's version of sword the peek space
station so sword is the offshoot from
shield shield is now in disarray after
being corrupted by Hydra so now it looks
like they may be Nick Fury may be
launching a new offshoot version of it
called sword you have their shield the
sword the sword and shield right so a
swords goal is to look out for
intergalactic and extraterrestrial
threats and their relationship to the
surface world so Nick Fury may be
heading this up and spoiler warning for
Wanda vision but there were these like
set photos that looks like sword may be
introduced in one division we saw
Harris's character Monica Rambeau
leaving a building that has the sword
logo and the acronym sword printed on it
so maybe Wanda vision will give us
another easter egg hinting at this sword
operation so getting back to how can it
connect to Secret Invasion the big twist
in Captain Marvel is that the scrolls
who in the comics are total baddies who
you can't trust their nefarious their
shapeshifters they're trying to corrupt
and infiltrate everything actually the
scrolls we met are pretty good there
they're working with Nick Fury
throughout the years yeah you know
they're just they're refugees and
they're helping them out now and
spider-man far from home so we have
actually been are the imperialist
[ __ ] so what if swords whole
objective is to help Nick Fury they are
a spy operation that he can trust and
there are actually the Secret Invasion
is really just CIA type assets that are
scattered around the globe
shape-shifting into people that are
government figures spies people who are
just trying to keep the status quo okay
trying to keep earth safe and giving the
scroll refugees a place to thrive and
give them a mission where they can work
with Nick Fury to keep earth safe yeah
but the big threat is that this has
leaked it's gotten out across the world
that there are these aliens who are
posing maybe one of them dies amongst us
imagine the term secretive Asian doesn't
that kind of sound like Jay jonah
Jameson's headline on his daily website
grid invasion rakes we have to find
these Scrolls amongst us fellow citizens
and drag them out in the street so that
we can finally be secure from further
extraterrestrial threats destroying our
way of life that's pretty good yeah the
lady in charge of where in the world is
Carmen Sandiego him and Luiz needed just
like recap so the whole threat will be
kind of similar to what we've seen in
certain spy movies right like a
terrorist rogue organization gets their
hands on the CI a CIA asset list and
they're gonna expose all these people in
the field and murder them but we need
these people we need these assets yeah
we gotta trust our intelligence sources
and it is a big threat that like
nefarious entities will expose FBI
agents in the field CIA agents in the
field that could really destroy a lot of
work that like decades and decades of
intelligence employees have done to try
to keep our world safe
imagine all the Jack Bauer's out in the
field all the terrorist incidents that
have been thwarted and prevented like
you don't want the public to know who
those people are we just gotta trust
that they're on the wall keeping us safe
good work that's being done so Nick
Fury's goal in this secretive agent
series is to try to keep his the
secretive agents actually a good one
that we need scrolls are implanted
around the world and we want to keep
them where they are and we want to keep
them safe because they're refugees but
they're really good at their job we want
to keep them safe on earth so they can
help keep us safe TV show or movie
though TV show TV okay week to week it's
gonna be interesting to see who's a
scroll who can you trust a little
there's a little bit of a homeland vibe
there where you know there's obviously a
mystery that is trying to uncover but
also can we really trust each of these
Scrolls and also identifying if you are
treating them as refugees we do have the
real world comparison thereof that's a
lot of fear of taking in refugees is
that there might be some bad actors that
are sneaking in along with refugees like
hey we're also here looking for
Asylum but actually they're secretly
working with some other government or
some other planet or thing what's really
cool by your theory though is that I'm a
big fan of how Marvel keeps being
inspired by what it's already done and
what's come before and to me you just
described a very good escalation to the
infiltration of shield by Hydra right
right and this is like what ruined
everything the Nick Fury had built was
realizing everyone around him almost
everyone was secretly a hydrogen so then
of course he's like well you know and
work yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna like
double down and do even further I'm
gonna replace everyone around the world
or tonnes be were on the world with my
version of that yes after shield but
Nick Fury's after shield let Nick Fury
down with Hydra Nick Fury's like who can
I trust
extraterrestrials good and banished from
their homeland let's try to keep them
safe in the field and the Secret
Invasion is actually something that we
need yeah I love it
Derek that's two rogue E's for you right
there yeah part of your show be that
when they're in trouble
Jack Bauer's the one that saves them a
little too loose with tortilla tortillas
and just straight Chloe's an Avenger now
great I love it okay
next I have one related to that I'm go
for it it's only because it is kind of
related to Eric's so my pitch is that
secret innovation is also TV show for
the set for similar reasons of like we
get to explore who people are and you
can change back and forth over the
course of the season and in a movie if
you change back and forth by the end
people will be frustrated it's like come
on you only have two hours to do this or
if you're Martin Scorsese five so I
think all right so in the first Captain
Marvel movie we see her chasing a scroll
on a train right and that scroll shape
shifts a bunch of times she's an old
woman
yeah it's great it's awesome and wish
fulfillment for you
take my seat why don't taking that
handicap seat like an ass and she never
actually catches that particular scroll
there's four Scrolls and three are
accounted for and that one gets away so
I think the secret invasion that in my
mind how we get into it and it could be
a teaser that we that it is dropped soon
or it's the first moments of the very
first episode we see still that exact
sequence of the scroll running away and
escaping from Captain Marvel and we see
where that scroll goes and what they do
and that scroll turns in back into Maria
hill it's a scroll that has always been
a spell in other words Maria Hill is a
scroll forever has never been like Maria
Hill the human mm-hmm interesting it's
always been a we see her be revealed as
a scroll far from home but I did notice
that you know waste when we see Nick
Fury revealed his house then we cut to
real no Maria Hills not there's always
my she's always been a scroll okay right
and now the this series is where's gonna
be one season until it leads to Captain
Marvel to because we don't have a
release date for that yet but I'm
betting it's gonna be not too far away
and it's not it's similar to Eric's
storyline in that yeah some scrolls are
good right but the basic premise is the
same as the comics which is that there
has been an actual invasion by Scrolls
most of them or at least looks I have to
be fair our bad and it's a it's a bad
invasion right so we're following the
Maria Hill scroll trying to actually
have this invasion going on at the same
time she's on the side of good right and
she's fighting the bad scrolls and so
Season one is like we actually learn
about the scrolls we see their history
we see how they came to earth which was
actually way before we think it was
before Captain Marvel and we see the
sort of origin story and how the battle
has been going on for ages and ages
season one is this battle happening
between good scrolls and bad scrolls
which
their complexity is the species a
species death not just character into it
and you rewrite it does go off of Erichs
because Maria Hill in that scenario
would be one of Fury's agent cities I
own has been a scroll this whole time
and is helping protect it it's so
connected to Erik said you do get one
Rogi Erik give you together the rules
can bend my rogue is because I pitched
Jack Bauer in his yeah if you if you
want their roadies just pitch exactly I
like marinas take on it because it is
true or to the secret evasion comics
which is just we do see the darker side
of the scroll people and there was
something good about that we don't have
to change everything for the shows like
let's let's just adapt it as it was and
like we can reveal different Avengers
that we know so far as potential Scrolls
the whole time um yes not technically an
Avenger but also my theory is that Hank
Pym is actually also yeah it would
explain a lot because he basically
invents like magic but you're you're the
timeline so okay so in Captain Marvel
that's as far as we know the first
appearance of Scrolls which is set in
the 90s 95 1989 with flash me yeah but
we've seen de-age Michael Douglas in
general implying he's he's been aging
along you know with the earth or
whatever so is he you're saying that
Scrolls were there before before that
mm-hmm and she just you know discovered
it or whatever you know that is
interesting because like the scrolls
have been in this refugee status
orbiting earth for a long period of time
like Wendy Lawson right like she was
working she was a Creed effective
working with them I don't know how long
they were working together or Bettina
round work that could've been as early
as the 70s or 60s
mmm wait but also
baby is wasp yeah so she's like a
quarter or I mean half cream is also a
scroll yeah or half scroll bullet myself
every night I I really like you're gonna
get a little a little half one on top of
that because these girls were here
before what we've seen and they had
already infiltrated that's right that's
very interesting I like it
joven I noticed earlier when Eric said
why change the comics your face
contorted and you cringed or something a
little bob because here's the thing uh I
you have a good twist in yours you you
go from like they're not the bad guys
that the good guys have been invading
you've got your you're good guys or
actually scrolls but I think that we
really need to look at not necessarily
what Marvel likes to do what Disney
likes to do and what we saw with Civil
War was a very different reimagine ation
of what civil war was and I think that
if we're maybe getting something Secret
Invasion it'll be along the same line so
they're gonna like the element will be
there but it's gonna be overall a very
different thing
quick reminder to people just Civil War
in the comics is a huge mass of a bad
there's a lot of characters going
underground and it's all about having
your identities revealing the spider-man
identity reveal happens in civil war and
it's after his career he's he's been
doing it which leads to him to die yeah
it does but uh
indie movie obviously it kind of is like
narrowed down about like the Avengers
which is emo turning side against yeah
yes
a civil war sorts but not the comic book
civil war and I think this might upset
some fans but it's kind of what they can
do is you already have so much happening
the MCU knowing that we're getting
multiverses with Doctor Strange in 2021
trying to throw in like who's who when
you might already have people coming
from other dimensions I think maybe
we'll see that happen first on the in
the Disney plus side of things
where there and keep that all connected
we know what we're getting from with
Captain America or Winter Soldier and
Falcon we know what we're getting with
long division the low key thing we don't
have a lot of details on and he's anis
sure cuz Eric made a nine-minute video
about but with him in a separate
timeline I think he's going to be coming
across a lot of characters that we've
seen in the MCU but with his we'll call
it magic but you know to the Norse gods
it's just their science maybe using the
tesseract and the magic that are the
powers that is embodied in that device
he's actually able to change people in
his timelines change their minds maybe
mind control with whatever he can do and
then start bringing people over to the
MCU timeline so it's not a scroll secret
invasion it's actually these mind wipes
characters that we've seen and known
from the other from the other timeline
now bringing brought into the MCU
timeline via Loki and his magic making
Loki another bad guy to be used in phase
four now that's about that one of the
issues with scrolls and being an
imposter is that obviously they don't
have the history of that character and
they also don't exactly have the real
strengths of that character if you
pretend to be the Hulk for instance
you're not actually as strong as the
Hulk if your scroll but these would be
actual versus that character versus that
character it's everyone's favorite cat
versus cat fight scene yeah yeah what
better to defeat someone who's as strong
as Scarlet Witch but by bringing back
her brother who has not yet died in the
local my alternate timeline Avengers
fighting this Avengers but what I might
even call them Dark Avengers it reminds
me of DC stories too would they do that
where the Justice League has encountered
other versions of the Justice League
before and they acts it's like the earth
- there's it and a lot of times they're
actually you could even introduce this a
little bit here and just straight up rip
it off but a lot of times their
existence is dependent on destroying
this one's existence they're kind of
like both needing to take their own ours
can't exist in the same space kind of
thing that is a vibe that you added
last part I'm okay with the power you
are thinking of Timecop you can't cross
the counters on the kitchen
[Music]
quicksilver come back and this is a
great way to do it no it's a great way
to bring just other characters that have
have either died or just give a
different take on it
I intend to have them invading and kind
of like derail and I love because we
avoid the the shapeshifter trope because
little done by having alternate versions
of them it's stakes are higher when
they're actually those people and you
know now like for instance you know
imagine hawkeye from a different reality
versus Ronan or something different
reality they both still have those
families you don't want either of them
technically the hot guy show I believe
it's coming after the Loki show so what
if Quebec I in that is actually maybe
that's our golden moment in in the Loki
series is we actually see him finding
Clint Barton maybe in like around
Avengers 1 or Thor 1 and actually mind
control I'm using this respect to take
over his mind and then bringing him over
and then that's the Hawkeye series that
yeah also I'll just throw out there
others play reality where it was Hawkeye
that died on your mirror and Black Widow
survives and that black widow can bring
her back I love it you get all of
marinus tech roadies every night you get
one rookie yeah but that's that's great
I'm very into these are some of the
better you guys did your homework this
week [ __ ] but a lot of times I'm just
looking at my watch the whole time be
like how did I shout louder to wake you
back yeah yeah yeah alright give them
back to me in a tweet okay so from the
ashes of shield Nick Fury assembles
sword a scroll spy organization
scroll wonder squirt a scroll worldwide
organization reconnaissance division hmm
pretty damn good
and that's my tree all right
Marino what's your all right
Secret Invasion :
dizzy plus series and then - and then
arrows - like in the text it's like
arrows and then it's it's arrows - Maria
hill equals the green face alien and
then more arrows - Captain Marvel -
that's my tweet just Captain Marvel did
the words Captain Marvel - mm-hmm
alright alright yeah Disney Plus does a
scroll secret invasion series with good
scrolls versus bad scrolls starting with
the lost scroll in Captain Marvel I
thought when you were doing all emojis
it took all her strength like Scrolls
yeah great that's it oh yeah a job in
Berea um Loki's causing havoc in an
alternate timeline taking all of your
favorite characters and bringing him
back but are they as they were why is
that so easy for him it's a lot of BS
and a lot of fake confidence mm together
moment he did a good thing where he
looked at me on the last word and it may
be
not because he's looking at me guys
before we talk about not getting we're
gonna talk about vision committing
really graphic murder yeah it's a
redemption for her vision I just a quick
shout out to some of the cool things
that we have going on in the rock stars
hey guys Eric here things get pretty
bold here her on the big question and
really we would love to take YouTube's
parental restrictions to the limits but
unfortunately some films they're just
too violent for us to go into all the
great detail on police publicly on this
channel so new rock stars is now
offering monthly bonus videos exclusive
to our generous patrons with unlisted
links that you can get by becoming a
patron of new rock stars Digital Studios
this month we broke down the Kingsmen
church scene a frame-by-frame here's a
clip of our breakdown then if we hit
another sneak cut on the digital zooms
that we are back to Colin Firth here for
the most crucial acting moment of this
entire sequence see the explosion causes
momentary deafness Harry's ears are
ringing and the freebird music fades
down for a moment and Colin Firth ever
so slightly shifts from berserk rage to
awareness shock confusion horror because
the ringing eardrums have blocked out
that simcard signal then the ringing
fades away free bird comes back and he
slips back and a berserk rage you can
access this plus all the other great
bonus videos we've made by becoming a
patron a day at patreon.com slash new
rock stars and thank you to all of our
lovely current patrons but they're
released of the Infinity Saga box set
which is freaking 500 and what like $85
or something we got a bunch of deleted
scenes from them the various Marvel
movies that are all part of the infinity
saga and Eric's been breaking down a
bunch of them and actually they kind of
have really interesting implications
about where they were gonna go with them
the infinity saga but also storylines
that they obviously are like well we can
still bring that back so it's really
cool stuff there but one deleted scene
made me so happy
and I think it actually fixed a
character for Eric yeah because Eric's a
hater on this one character and it's one
scene vision is having his fight against
Corvus glaive an infinity war and it's
I think he had stabbed in the back or
something when he gets killed an
infinity war his vision phase shifts his
hand inside of Corvus glaive grabs his
heart we see it and crushes it or like
tears it apart with his bare hands in
there which is a move that vision could
have done to anyone at any point in any
fight just like I mean in fact if you
did there goes brain what in there he's
like made him say so it was such a
mazing moment it's one of the really
rare times where a superhero actually
use their powers to the fullest extent I
know the characters were deemed a bit
for you if if you had just done this
from the beginning I'd be like yes I can
get on board with vision but now he's
just kind of a boring robot well he's a
very moral individual and that's why
he's able but I'm excited for Wanda
vision it's like okay maybe a good take
on vision but so far sorry Paul Bettany
but I'm happy you do okay so I well I
know that start your puppet Annie is
alive and well sorry or watch this in 26
okay so I'm gonna let you guys stay dark
though and I'm gonna let you guys get
into your heads and get all gross about
this for a second if you guys are the
kind of people that don't watch an
r-rated movie because there's too much
violence maybe this section isn't for
you turn off your imagination yes
everyone transition okay I want you guys
to pitch me on some potential ways that
other Marvel characters could actually
fully use their abilities in a way that
honestly is probably how it would happen
in real life like on the boys yeah okay
I think as much as I loved the infinity
war and end game films we did not get to
see the full potential of the Infinity
stones and the Infinity Gauntlet yes
specifically ones like the reality stone
and the time stone they are only used
when it's convenient for the plot but in
no other way that if one of us had this
we would go apeshit one of these guys
the reality stone currently is exactly
as powerful as the villain and far from
home technology it's as powerful as a HD
projector on fog because that's all it
does it turns someone temporarily into
Bloxx
someone temporarily into ribbons it
makes really the blaster-bolt of his gun
turn into bubbles and then as soon as he
leaves the scene
I guess he's out of the Wi-Fi signal
radius and it goes back to normal
it is useless it is useless so but as
far as we know an MCU cannon that's as
powerful as reality stone is at one
point he does use it to cause the ground
beneath dr. Strange's feet on Titan roll
in on itself to drag him in like a
carpet that you roll towards someone you
know when you're fighting somebody
breath okay turns you into your fists
but I think there's something that could
be done either with the reality stone or
the time stone specifically mom but
surgical uses so I want to see Thanos
you or someone use the time stone either
in this reality or another one to
disrupt the heartbeat of because we saw
how the the focus of the time stone can
be directed towards an apple right the
Apple is just a specific organ within
someone's body use the time stone to age
up their liver so that it can no longer
process bile in your body and you rot
from the inside out you get jaundice and
what a slow way to take someone out or
just their heartbeat our heartbeat needs
to have us like people have like a
rhythmic arrhythmia yeah so if you just
go it's or magic what if you just pull
it out just a little wider to a person I
do think it's very funny if like in a
battle winter soldiers running at him
and he just aims it Adam any ageism
oh man like Nana Jones like you drinks
from the like immediately like becomes
like a powder turns into dust but in a
cooler way deterrence when it denies
what if you just aged their sperm so
they can't have kids
what is aged sperm do different it gets
too tired to work his way let you come
to me I just think we're you age just
their eyeballs so they walk off a pier
injury what old person did this to many
leading cause of death among the old not
there in the traffic appearing yeah I
think there's so much that could be done
like just with it I mean if your power
of time you are god of this universe and
that is the only infinity stone yeah
literally they were fighting God and
instead he made bubbles like he was able
that once he destroyed the mine stone he
was able to just like turn it back like
at that point he should have went for
the time stone first yeah that's really
great oh also he could be really funny
if two people are running out of me
makes one inch of the old man and went
into a baby okay I like it
Eric you get Rogi this thing is a little
baby Rogi this one you've never given
out before it is a gray oldie oldie
[Laughter]
what does it mean I keep losing half
points every minute what you added I'm
confused to the rules of it but okay no
you have to keep this
just put them in there okay go now
you're at it's complicated you're at two
[Music]
I felt very inspired because now also
someone's you said was about going down
the route of the boys and that kind of
took where I was going and not
originally I was you not when I look at
you yeah original just gonna go in a
very dark place but I'm like oh now we
can go to a really messed up place so if
you guys I think the best interpretation
of a villain in the MCU has actually
been purple man yes kill grave kill
grave was absolutely amazing because i
think that is an actual progression of
what a normal person who then gets
powers not even normal person with
person with powers then can become this
and I think if we look at Doctor Strange
as a character uh he's kind of a dick
and then all of a sudden he gets wizard
like powers and how would that actually
change and evolve his character I think
there's a place where he could have
actually gone to really just use his
powers in a messed up way and I'm
talking about whether he's fighting good
guys or bad guys whatever path he
decides to take he he actually finds
that's it's for example give me any MCU
villain Doctor Doom Doctor Doom all
right he goes and finds Doctor Doom and
then because Doctor Strange has the
ability canonically to like look into
other dimensions and see who's there now
maybe even open portals to other
dimensions pull doctor dooms family into
this universe it's like Doctor Doom I
see what you're doing I'm gonna kill
your family right in front of you oh my
god he's pulling a Jack Bauer threatened
people's families Jack Bauer tied you to
upside down and he electrocuted you with
lamp you only saw what you said you that
we know yeah exactly those were the
seasons you saw I always skip ten years
how many other unknown terrorist
incidents were thwarted by unknown
families being using the boys it's kind
of like a reference we see where they'd
sure that heroes will just go to very
dark places to get the job done it's
been saving the world yeah and if it's
not part of your specific timeline maybe
like dooms families actually still alive
but he's pulling this other earth 33
family so it's like maybe he has a less
connection to it again okay it's just
like if he knows an infinite amount of
characters yeah then it's just like it's
just another one dying they die all the
time so he can kill someone in front of
Doctor Doom to get them to stop what's
happening you know if he's seen 14
million different realities or whatever
based on on using the time stone that
way he kind of is like a little detached
you died by tripping on that SP earlier
so like I've already lost you 14 Rick
Sanchez exactly so interesting just go
to like really you can mess with the
body and you'll die instantaneously you
mess with their head there's stuff like
that for life yeah he learned that with
Dormammu right like kill me as many
times as you want I'm gonna like torture
you mentally yeah interesting it's
already there for him to walk across
yeah
have you used anything like this in your
life like to get where you are yes but I
shall not say what those are yet till my
dying day
yeah now I'm looking at you so now you
nod that's fine we find out next week
then great your dying day kind of but
just because I'm giving it to and boys
been nice to you pray that I don't have
access to other dimensions like you make
all three rookies face in and stare you
real simple straightforward
Hulk punches harder yeah I mean
basically it's not these it's a membrane
em game when the big ol ship comes and
Captain Marvel just like straight-up fly
through it remember that yes the whole
last ship she just flies through it
basically she just does that for
everything and and just slice everything
and and and everybody else's job is to
line up her problem like pin like pins
like bowling pins and then she just like
goes through all of them Doctor Strange
is opening part
that they're following through yes fine
yeah yeah popping people
yeah she's running into people the boys
the beginning of the boy is wait hold on
Kim Marina Eric can you remind us the
physical dimensions of what happens we
get the boys you want Serena active okay
move in with me oh but you're gonna have
to take down your stupid Billy Joel
posters she hit her head on the light if
you haven't seen season one of the boys
you now don't need to that's it that was
all of it I like that you guys did not
acknowledge the speedster happening at
all she just spontaneously just move so
fast so Captain Marvel just just turns
everyone into a balloon and she's a
bullet I don't think she moves as fast
as a trainer or the flash so it's not
like this instantaneous so hard you did
yeah so then it's just like in one and
how they have to line everyone up
perfectly so the bullets go through so
they can do the whipping boy so here
here's the IRS guy he's trying to get
you to pay more here's your landlord who
is like too mean to you and here's that
scary talk okay and here's dr. doom and
just bro
all right marina I'm gonna give you
we're going to speed this up in post I'm
gonna give you this whole stack oh geez
oh this seems good but being on here
twice I now know this might not go as
well for her as we hope okay marina uh
and then we'll use the golden Rogi that
rarely shows up because it represents
when Carol Danvers kicks into high gear
well you get as many rogue ease as stay
standing on this stack but you need to
hit it as hard
okay with Captain Marvel as you you've
been talking about so yes I'm throwing
it stay wait no no no I can't can't
trust you just go
who's our biggest competitor Erik all
right Erik use use well yeah exactly she
stole from you earlier remember that
area you're gonna hit it as hard as
carol danvers would hit it and whichever
ones are still basically in place should
I get
okay Erik remember remember our history
remember our trust in our friendship all
right and they all exploded great all
right give them back to me in tweets
your do disgusting little imaginative
tweets wait wait wait I have mine now
Carol Danvers is a bowling ball yeah
yeah Thanos is going to make your eyes
and old man's eyes so you walk off of
cliff reply
Erik you okay Doctor Strange pulls from
alternate dimensions to kill his enemies
families in front of them checking on
Erik great alright and let's do right
before we go into row questions let's do
a point total recap for sure but as we
all know Road questions can change
everything but marina is in a bar lead
right now
she's like Joe Biden so what could
happen guys movie theaters have changed
the name of birds of prey to Harley
Quinn : birds of prey to increase ticket
sales somehow pitch me on an even more
click Beatty version of the title Harley
Quinn this time she's in in shorts
shorts last time too but they got my
money anyway yeah how the Quinn
beating up bad guys yeah Arkham doctors
hate her Harlequin special secret to do
your perfect makeup that's a rugby fan
yeah all right guys
a standard poodle one a standard poodle
not an enhancer won Best in Show at the
Westminster Dog Show this week pitch me
on what the best dog breed is best dog
breed German Shepherd and I'll tell you
why yep because if you're a little girl
a little girl but if you're like a small
framed woman like me and you have a big
dog like that nobody [ __ ] with you I'm
going rogue on this one I'm gonna say
whatever the dog was from that first
Hulk movie it's a nice dog but then can
Hulk out when you need it to yeah the
best dog breed is no breed because
breeding dogs is cruel and every dog
should be mud semester's but this is
true a German Shepherd saved my mom's
life she was in when she was a little
girl now guys the Halloween novelty song
Monster Mash is getting turned into an
entire movie musical give me your best
maybe like two or three lines from the
hit song from the monster Monster Mash
musical we're monsters but we're not
here to hurt you all we need is a little
understanding okay no one told me she
had music talent why would that have
made a difference you wouldn't have come
concise it doesn't rhyme but it but it
tells you the story you should have
looked at me know what a knob hey this
movie's pretty grey but nobody pay
attention to the fact that we did this
already with a Mumma monster movie bash
movie in the 80s and it was stop-motion
the Mook mom matzo movie mash in the
movie one person do ups
on purpose just pound her gash that is
to rookies for - and slash was mad
monster parties but I fully support that
smashing the gash like you pound your
gas so you don't scrape your gash
alright so let's get point totals
quarter rogue a great job and he got a
2.25 not bad for you came out hot and
then you got really into this monster
thing he didn't know how to count on his
on there so joven you will never come
true while not the marina had the same
witches job and Eric everyone must
scroll shape-shift into a different
person
Eric who are you gonna become I'll
become joven so transform hi I'm Erik
Bosse I know all things about comic
books and science yeah
you stupid idiot you read you made
yourself look like joven yes I don't get
out blocks work joven air you already
looked like Eric really just messes me
up yeah I love it
alright joven your turn now obviously uh
dude I I look at what you're bringing to
the table over here for Zeke wise I'm
shifting into you
oh okay I'm gonna become Eric oh hey
look I'm Eric Weiss are you know stand
in front of a blue screen and shout and
then because I make a bunch of nerd
references that people like me and
artists mean to me in the Commons barely
open your mouth it's a heavier mouth
it's a heavy mouth shut up the squeals
real know I'll become you my shirts are
all so big I'll never fit in anything
right that's it for this episode of
rogue theory oh my god I have boobies
now thanks thanks for going broke with
us thanks to I guess marina Mastro's
[Music]
Joshua / Shire I get confused
I'm Erik Bosse feed and stay tuned to
the YouTube channel for this another
belt you can lower your voice okay okay
this is know me back to normal Philip
but I'm in marinas body follow us on
Twitter and new rock stars follow me at
Philip Malina my shirt is smaller
because of my muzzle
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]